before getting into this video i just
wanted to say if you're new here please
subscribe and don't forget to turn your
notifications below on also if you're a
filmmaker and want to get involved in
future collaborations filmmaking
projects or conversations to learn more
about filmmaking traveling the world and
just to connect with other like-minded
people click on the discord invitation
link below i've written in caps
cool back to the video
i've always had this idea to make a film
about happiness what is happiness rarely
and how does one understand it and get
more of it but this idea is so much
bigger than what i can capture alone
that's why i recruited 100 filmmakers
from around the globe to show me what
makes them happy
this is that story
hey i'm don mace i've carried this book
around with me for the past 10 years
it's filled with the most challenging
ideas i've ever had and this show is
dedicated to getting them done
welcome to the brew show
[Music]
i just first off wanted to say thank you
so so much for wanting to be a part of
this it's so amazing to be able to work
with
filmmakers from around the world the
objective is to try and make the
happiest film on the internet and
essentially give people 100 reasons to
smile so it will come from each and
every single one of you i in no way want
to affect
the outcome of this video we want to
keep it completely directed by each and
every single one of you i want to create
this film as a reason for people to feel
connected to other people around the
world that's awesome yeah pretty excited
yeah yeah
awesome guys thank you so much
testing testing testing
i've just finished going through 1460
clips from around the world which is 700
gigabytes and around 12 hours of
playback in a timeline this footage was
contributed from more than 100
filmmakers from all around the world and
it's emotional my challenge now is to
edit this to not try and affect it to
keep it raw the way in which the
different filmmakers from around the
world have answered this question
visually so yeah that's what i'm gonna
do right now and i'll check in with you
when i'm done
[Music]
okay cool i'm gonna render this out and
then
i'm gonna play it to you i hope you
enjoy it as much as i did making it with
all of these amazing filmmakers
what does happiness mean to me
happiness is
something that the world needs right now
it's the connection we have to all
living things
being a human in this world being
amongst the millions and billions of
beautiful human beings on planet earth
[Music]
maybe being truly happy is when we stop
questioning what it means and just live
it
but it's often also the little things
that make me happy
listening to good music on the way to
work
and trying on cool vintage stuff
watching the water crash against the
rocks
spending time with the person that makes
me feel special
from time to time i like to look up at
the stars at night
if i'm having a bad day sometimes all it
takes is putting in headphones and
listening to a tune so beautiful i have
to get up and dance along to the beat
when i play music and when i hit those
damn notes on the spot
come on
[Music]
it's feeling something so deeply that i
can't quite express
happiness isn't rare it's just hidden
and the best way to find it is to
stumble across it
the feeling of being the chosen one for
such coincidence i'm happy because
the people around me are happy and if i
can make them happy
i'm the happiest guy in the world
well happiness to me is letting my inner
child out today
[Music]
that's like like meeting up with friends
family
growing and learning and being able to
look back
at all the memories you make along this
journey
[Music]
there's this thing that happens
a moment of stillness
where it's like time stops and the
beauty is just there
the beauty's been there the whole time
but maybe you were just too busy to see
it it could be a warm smile from a
passerby
a hug from a loved one
sunrises make me really happy
it makes me feel more connected to
everyone
this understanding that the sun i'm
watching from here
is the same sun for everyone no matter
where they are in the world
oh that's cool that's happiness
connor it's telling stories whether it
may be your own or told from generation
to generation
happiness is not something that we do or
say but it is something that we feel and
share with others
just look into the eyes of a loved one
and you'll see it too
and thinking there is nowhere else i'd
rather be but right now
[Music]
cheers
i really hope you enjoyed this film and
i just wanted to say thank you again so
much to all the filmmakers from around
the world that contributed and then
thank you so much to discovery plus for
the opportunity to work with all these
filmmakers and of course for making the
brew series come to life discovery plus
is the home of truly great filmmaking
and storytelling i believe in story
first and most of the time when creating
documentary style content and dealing
with so much footage it's really
difficult to string together a narrative
and that's where i reference discovery
plus documentaries which in my opinion
are the greatest in the game and that's
where i learned to grow my storytelling
skills and one of my favorite
documentaries at the moment is uprooted
directed by avril c speaks and if you
sign up now you get a 14 day discovery
plus promotion using the promo code
danmese this offer is valid until the
25th of june 2022 so click on the link
in the description to redeem your
promotion now yeah don't forget to
subscribe and turn your notifications
below on other than that don't forget
you're awesome brew and i'll see you
soon
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
[Music]
mmm
[Music]